if it's fresh air you're after
the humber bridge is a pretty good walk
it's also the gateway to the uk's new
covid hotspot
the royal infirmary in hull has lost 50
patients to coronavirus
in the past fortnight the boss here
is scaling up their response redeploying
staff
and says the english lockdown
restrictions are no longer enough in
this city
a lot of people are almost going about
their normal lives
i think we need tighter restrictions we
saw how the total lockdown in wave one
worked
and i think we need to be looking um
much more uh at that sort of approach
as we approach the peak of wave two so
for you that would include schools
in hull i'm afraid it would have to and
in other parts of the country of course
at hull's marina the dog walkers were
out
pie the greyhound was hungry just leave
it
a lot of people want to spend christmas
with their families it's like you've got
to knuckle down now and follow the rules
kids are very asymptomatic as a general
rule but they're one of the higher sort
of vectors for it spreading so i think
possibly we really should have locked
the schools down again yeah i think some
people are really paranoid about it and
some people are quite less it fair
and i think it's really difficult
there's such diverse views across the
city
i think people want to do the right
thing but i think they've got a little
bit punch drunk and i think a little bit
tired of it i'm honest with you
also out clearing her head was cynthia
who works at the hospital
people are dying from this it's a lot
it's affecting a lot of people it's
tempting to want to visit loved ones as
much as you can i i would love to go to
london to visit my family i miss them a
lot
but i have to obey the rules and there's
a lot down for a reason
everyone here is being asked to do their
bit
this is the pressure point for humber
side the point that so many other areas
of the north of england have faced
in this second wave the next few weeks
here
will test the health service to its
absolute limit
this city fared relatively well in the
first phase of the virus in the spring
but this tide has now turned tom
parmenter
sky news humberside